- - Stéphanie Grammond, Michel C
AuAuger et Alex Castonguay,
bobonsoir.
JeJe vais commencer par l'Pandoa
PaPapers. Stéphanie, puisqu'on
n'n'en parle depuis toujours, e-
cece qu'il y a eu du progrès? On
esest encore à peu près au même.
DeDevant ce phénomène d'une
prprofessionnalisation extrême s
fifiscalistes et bureaux d'avocs
ququi font que des gens très
ririches s'en sortent mieux.
- - Envoie des révélations comme
cecelle-là, pour le contribuable
momoyen comme vous et moi qui
papayons nos impôts au grand
cocomplet, ça donne mal au coeue
vovoir qu'il y a des riches come
çaça qui sentirent en allant das
dedes paradis fiscaux. Il y a
ququand même des efforts qui sot
fafaits. L'OCDE a mis en place,l
y y a eu des annonces qui ont éé
fafaites dans le dernier mois,
popour essayer de s'attaquer aux
mumultinationales et à la
coconcurrence fiscale que le pas
sese livrait entre. Il va
nonormalement y avoir quelque
chchose qui va ressembler à un
imimpôt minimal de 15 % pour les
grgrandes entreprises. Mais ce
ququ'on aimerait voir maintenan,
c'c'est des lois qui s'appliquet
auaux riches, pas seulement aux
enentreprises, mais aussi aux
inindividus. On dirait que c'est
lele dernier bouquet manque. Il
fafaudrait qu'il y ait une
apapplication de tout ça. C'est
bebeau d'avoir des lois, encore
fafaut-il ensuite aller chercher
l'l'argent. C'est loin d'être
fafacile. On veut éviter des
d'd'avoir le fisc qui passe come
unun grand chalutier qui ramasse
leles gens qui n'ont pas grand-
chchose à se reprocher, comme on
l'l'a vu dans le passé, mais qui
lalaisse les poissons exotiques
dadans l'paradis fiscaux, les gs
popoissons plus difficiles
atattrappé. Euh, il les laisse
nanager parce que c'est plus
cocompliqué de s'attraper, de
s's'attaquer à des riches et
pupuissants cas des gens ici au
QuQuébec.
- - La solution doit
nénécessairement venir par
l'l'international, parce que s'l
rereste un seul paradis fiscal.a
babanque du Vatican déjà été un
paparadis fiscal. S'il en reste
jujuste, ils vont aller là. Il a
unune multiplication, les
ététudiants et, Luxembourg,
DéDétroit, Saint-Martin. C'est a
ququ'il faut fermer. Ça ne se fa
quque c'est les grandes puissans
sese mette d'accord pour terminr
cece trafic là. On parle de bien
bebelles choses à CDO et ailleu,
mamais à la fin, ça marche pas
totoujours.
- - Au bout du compte, c'est de
l'l'argent de moins dans des
cocoffres d'État.
- - Puis c'est compliqué, par ce
quque dès qu'il y a un état ou s
ététats qui vont faire faux bonà
lala communauté internationale,
totout le château de cartes
s's'effondre. On a l'impression
quque chaque pays a un peu son
prpropre paradis fiscal et ça ft
bibien leur affaire. Les
BrBritanniques ont le Virgin
IsIsland, les Américains le
DeDelaware, les Français dans le
LuLuxembourg. C'est toujours la
fafaute de l'autre. C'est jamais
soson propre paradis fiscal qui
esest le problème. C'est très
cocomplexe. Même les états ont
popour avoir un peu plus de
vivigueur comme le Canada, on st
quque c'est lent. On attend les
auautres. Dans le dernier budget
dedes Chrystia Freeland, il y
avavait une mesure qui disait
auauCanada, on ne pouvait plus
enenregistrer des compagnies à
nunuméro 110 qui était le
vévéritable propriétaire de
l'l'entreprise, pour qu'on puise
sasavoir qui sont les
prpropriétaires des compagnies à
nunuméro. Pas pouvoir se cacher
dederrière ça, ça serait bien.
MaMais la mise en application et
prprévue en 2025. On donne quate
anans entreprises pour s'adapte.
LeLes entreprises ont se disent
ququ'ils ont encore le temps.
- - Dans les milliers de noms qi
sosont sortis, il faut quand mêe
sosouligner qu'il n'y a pas de
popoliticiens, d'élus canadiens.
IlIl y a Jacques Villeneuve,
enenquête va donner plus de
dédétails sur Monsieur Villeneue
jejeudi soir. Il y a des inconn,
j'j'entendais notre journaliste
ququi parlait d'inconnus, s'il
avavait fallu qu'il y ait des
nonoms, des Tonie Blair canadie,
onon aurait parlé de ça sur un
auautre temps. J'ai). Monsieur
LeLegault a dit que sonton n'étt
papas le ton idéal la semaine
dedernière. Je vous fais lorsqul
écécrit sur sa page Facebook :
unun mea culpa qui était
nénécessaire selon vous?
- - Absolument nécessaire. On a
totout le droit d'avoir une
mamauvaise semaine. Monsieur
LeLegault a une mauvaise semaine
lala semaine dernière. Mais il
avavait l'air du gars qui quittt
lele banc des punitions pour alr
sese battre encore. C'est pas le
rrôle du premier ministre. C'est
inindigne de l'Assemblée
nanationale. J'étais très heurex
dede voir Monsieurur Legault fae
cecette mise au point. Elle état
nénécessaire. Il faut ce qu'il
s's'ajuste au discours des
QuQuébécois. Toute son histoire
susur le racisme systémique,...
c'c'est souvent des choses
ininvolontaires, une loi qui a s
efeffets non prévus, des choses
cocomme ça. 92 % des Québécois
dadans un sondage cheztt disaiet
ququ'il croit que les autochtons
sosont victimes de discriminatin
raraciste. De quoi Monsieur
LeLegault a-t-il peur?
- - Il serait étonnant que
MoMonsieur Legault change d'idée
llà-dessus.
- - Il est allé trop loin dans a
rhrhétorique pour faire volte-
faface. Par contre, dans le tem,
çaça peut être adapté. C'est bin
ququ'il ait reconnu que ça avait
unune semaine difficile sur ce
plplan là. Depuis quelques
sesemaines, François Legault un
toton qui est peut-être un peu
ininapproprié par rapport aux
momoments politiques où on se
trtrouve. On a l'impression qu'l
vava être en campagne électorale
dadans deux semaines et puis ila
unun niveau d'énergie et
d'd'agressivité qui ne semble ps
totout à fait en accord avec
l'l'ambiance. Quand c'est pas
GaGabriel Nadeau-Dubois qui estn
wowoke, c'est qu'on ne veut pas
fafaire de journée fériée au
QuQuébec parce qu'on a besoin de
prproductivité. Je ne sais pas i
aiaide à François Legault qu'il
fafallait absolument qu'il soitn
momode attaque pendant toute
l'l'année, Mélanie va être long.
CeCe qui lui a permis d'être aui
popopulaire, c'est justement le
toton un peu plus rassembleur,
emempathique adopté pendant la
papandémie. On a l'impression qe
lala seule chose qu'il souhaite
fafaire, c'est polarisé surtoute
dédébat qui lui passe sous le nz
dedepuis maintenant un mois. J'i
papas l'impression que c'est un
toton en accord avec ce que les
gegens attendent à ce temps-ci e
l'l'année e politique.
- - Je suis d'accord avec mes
cocollègues. Il n'avait absolumt
papas le bon temps la semaine
dedernière, d'aller dire des
chchoses comme ça le jour même n
cécélébrait le premier
ananniversaire du décès de Joyce
EcEchaquan. C'était extrêmement
mamalvenu. Ce qui m'attriste qud
jeje vois tout ça, c'est qu'on
fafait débat autour du terme
raracisme systémique et puis pe-
êêtre que Monsieur Legault
popourrait se peinturer dans un
cocoin, ça ne tue pas personne e
mamarcher sur la peinture. Maisn
nene s'attaque pas aux vrais
enenjeux. On a vu la semaine
dedernière que l'recommandationu
rarapport vient, qui s'attaquait
auaux problèmes entre les
auautochtones et les services
pupublics, il n'y a à peu près s
dede chemin qui a été fait sur s
rerecommandations. Il y a une
foformation qui avait été mise n
oeoeuvre dans les services de sé
susuite à la mort de Joyce
EcEchaquan, il y a seulement 1 %
dedes gens qui l'ont suivi. On
sasait que c'est l'pandémie, mas
ququand même. Quand on regarde u
ccôté des services de la DPJ, il
y y a une solution qui avait été
mimise de l'avant pour que les
auautochtones puissent occuper
dadavantage de leurs enfants et
QuQuébec, pour une question de
jujuridiction, met des bâtons ds
leles roues. Tout ça, c'est des
dodossiers, au-delà du vocabulae
ututilisé, il y a toutes ces
memesures concrètes auquel il ft
s's'attaquer.
- - Prorogation de la session,
c'c'est un classique. Vous parlz
dede ton, de niveau. Ça aide qud
onon reprend, il y a un grand
didiscours, on place les
obobjectifs. Ça peut peut-être
apapaiser un peu les choses, no?
- - Oui, mais ça va demeurer une
élélection, une année électoral.
L'L'élection aura lieu le 3
nonovembre l'an prochain... le 3
ococtobre, plutôt.
CeCela permet d'enlever le bois
momort. Le projet de loi ne meut
plplus au feuilleton et on peute
raramener à l'étape où ils
ététaient. Il y a encore un prot
dede loi sur la réforme du modee
scscrutin qui est sur la table e
l'l'Assemblée nationale. Ça ne
papassera pas. Ça permet de se
fofocaliser sur ce qu'on veut
fafaire dans la dernière année u
mamandat, adopter ce qui est
imimportant, probablement les
amamendements à la loi 101. Il y
auaura un projet de loi dit
mamammouth que Monsieur Dubé pet
lele faire passer. En même temp,
ilil y a toujours un danger, ça
papasse vite la première année e
mamandat et le gouvernement
prpropose, l'opposition dispose.
CÇa peut aussi faire des
flflammèches.
- - Le contexte a changé. La
papandémie, on commence à avoirn
apapaisement. Il est quelque che
dede normal, alors j'étais étoné
quque l'opposition aujourd'hui
didise que la prorogation est
épépouvantable. Le projet de loi
nene tombe pas à la trappe non
plplus.
- - C'est un peu la vieille
cacassette des partis d'oppositn
ququi dise que c'est un exercice
ininutile. Mais c'est à propos.
DeDepuis un an et demi,
gogouvernement du Québec est
ococcupé à gérer une pandémie.
MoMonsieur Legault a un peu peru
lala carte côtière mise en place
avavant la pandémie. C'est bien
ququ'ils disent qu'il veut se
rerendre à destination et voicie
ququ'il va prioriser. Il y a des
chchoses qui ne seront pas
acaccomplies, mais il reste ence
asassez deux semaines et deux ms
popour accomplir certains grand-
paparents de ce qui était prévu.
LeLesquels, dans quel domaine v-
t-t-on aller? La santé, les
seservices de garde? Qu'il nous
prprécise pourquoi elle va mette
soson énergie pendant la dizaine
dede mois avant l'été après ça,e
sesera la campagne électorale.
C'C'est tout à fait normal qu'on
esessaie de remettre les comptes
àà zéro à ce temps-ci du mandat.
- - On a rarement vu ça aussi
lolongtemps, le premier ministre
avavec un taux de satisfaction
auaussi grand. On va voir des
tatableaux défilés. 65 % qui sot
sasatisfaits! Cela donnent des
inintentions de vote, au prochan
tatableau, Monsieur Legault dome
tototalement le jeu politique
ququébécois avec 40 % d'appui.
LeLe Parti conservateur et avec
popour cent, il faut surveiller.
StStéphanie Grammond, M. Legaul,
ququi a fait la synthèse des
féfédéralistes, des
sosouverainistes, ils récoltent
cecette synthèse encore pas mal?
- - C'est quand même phénoménal
leles résultats des sondages qun
vovoit en ce moment! On aurait u
imimaginer avoir certains ne que
FrFrançois Legault a attrapé
dedernièrement. Il s'est prononé
enen faveur des conservateurs ax
dedernières élections. Finaleme,
c'c'est Justin Trudeau qui a été
lulu. On parlait des ratés et du
toton plus acrimonie au cours de
lala dernière semaine, même un u
plplus. On pourrait imaginer qul
y y aurait peut-être une petite
babaisse dans les sondages, mais
ilil n'y en a pas du tout.
- - Ça prend du temps avant
d'd'égratigner une carapace de
l'l'épaisseur de celle de Françs
LeLegault. Ce ne sont pas les
dederniers événements qui vont
alaller perdre des plumes. Mais
pepeut se passer des choses dans
lala prochaine année mais
clclairement, actuellement, c'et
lele premier ministre le plus
popopulaire depuis tellement
lolongtemps. Être aussi en avane
dadans les intentions de vote à
unune dernière année de mandat,n
a a jamais vu ça.
- - Il y a deux raisons à ça. Sr
lele plan, Monsieur Legault done
auaux Québécois exactement ce
ququ'ils veulent, le PQ à saveur
plplus économique avec pas de
réréférendum. D'autre part,
l'l'opposition est morcelée en
trtrois et elle n'a pas trouvé e
chcheval de bataille. Pas encore
trtrouvé de façons d'attaquer le
gogouvernement. Mais c'est pas
fafacile de faire cependant une
papandémie. On verra si une anne
sasans pandémie va changer la